right wing actor kevin sorbo made a  really weird analogy to abortion on  twitter where he said you mix  ingredients to make a cake knowing that  these are the ingredients for a cake  you put the cake in the oven and then  you throw it away because you decide you  don't want cake and it's not a cake  until it's fully cooked what's  fascinating about that is step two put  the cake in the oven  it's not yet a cake it's batter  it's just batter that's all it is  nobody would say  if you have uncooked  cake batter on the counter  that that's a cake  i don't know anyone that would it's a  bizarre analogy and just the latest in a  very strange series of tweets from sorbo  weird dude